qu'est ce que tous les soirs l'humoriste
mathieu dufour donne rendez-vous à des
milliers d'abonnés sur instagram pour
son émission le show rona virus onze
mille deux cents personnes sont en effet
depuis qu'il nous dit comment depuis les
gens sont vraiment contents
soyez l'homme qui m'ont donné la
cinquième salle de la place des arts
l'idée a germé un peu par hasard alors
qu'il était en direct sur sa page pour
remercier ses abonnés le moment
coïncidait avec le début du confinement
depuis maintenant des semaines des gens
du public et des artistes se joindre à
lui
parfois de façon spontanée horatio ndéné
ndiaye de nous les gens ce qui m'a écrit
tu sais que dans leur confinement si ça
va moins bien tu es en a qui ont perdu
leur emploi il y en a qui vivent un
stress financier en extrait c'est aussi
par rapport à des baies virus le message
qui me revient si ça permet aux gens de
décrocher un autre humoriste peut le
confirmer
[Musique]
jean marc parent à relancer de façon
virtuelle son émission d'humour des
années 90 l'heure jmp spécialement pour
accompagner le public en temps de crise
je pense on interdit d'amener parce que
ça me touche également à diversifier man
2 me fait rire dans ce dur moment parce
que j'ai eue là nous qui sommes afin que
mon père est décédé
ça nous fait du bien une charge des
idées on passe à autre chose faite
autres baptistes équipe est bien
embarquer là-dedans gratuitement puis on
fait le temps de la part des nuits après
des semaines de réclusion le succès de
ces plateformes des changes ne donne pas
la psychologue stéphanie léonard qui
traite entre autres les troubles anxieux
et ainsi que le super ce salon se sentir
connecter aux ordres sans saccades et
j'entends de nous c'est vraiment
facteurs protecteurs surtout dans des
moments d'épreuves comme on vit en ce
moment
cette blogueuse à l'onf et la même
initiative à plus petite échelle
on parle des sujets qui nous touchent
directement puisse-t-elle jeudi une
série de nous offre pas ça bientôt le
déconfinement sa mort sera graduellement
et ces discussions éphémères ont aidé
des centaines de milliers de personnes a
traversé le pic de la crise et si
mélissa françois radio canada montréal